qui est inspecteur et responsable des
communications pour paroles
organisationnelles du SPVM bonjour merci
d'être avec nous fait plaisir
de 2009 alors il y a plusieurs résumés
victimes là qui ont été interrogés par
les policiers mais finalement ça a pas
abouti tout ça est-ce que maintenant le
SPVM doit refaire ses devoirs
2008-2009 effectivement votre votre
reportage enquête révélé l'enquête du
SPVM le dossier en tant que tel a été
soumis au Directeur des poursuites
criminels et pénales alors et suite à ça
le dossier n'a pas apporter l'addition
était ne pas porter d'accusation
effectivement donc ça s'est rendu au
DPCP c'est un procureur qui a décidé
qu'on allait pas plus loin l'histoire ne
dit pas pourquoi ceci dit si on suit au
témoignage de ces de ces femmes qui ont
parlé avec notre équipe d'enquête il y
en a qui ont pas aimé du tout leur
expérience avec les policiers puis on
sait à quel point c'est un enjeu quand
on parle de ce type de crime elles
disent qu'elles été traités dans
certains cas comme si c'était elle le
criminel est-ce que ça se peut
effectivement qu'elles aient été mal
reçues ben je vous dirais madame Dolley
mais tout d'abord je peux pas vous
donner des détails précis concernant
l'enquête nécessairement discrétion des
policiers qui nous en empêchent
cependant ce que je peux vous dire de
façon générale c'est que ospvm les
victimes sont au cœur des enquêtes en
matière d'exploitation sexuelle le
personnel qui mène ce genre de dossier
là c'est des gens qui sont attentionnés
qui respectent la dignité des victimes
et qui sont là pour leur expliquer le
processus et les accompagner tout au
long alors dépendamment des situations
dépendamment des rencontres des
parlements du statut de la personne
qu'on rencontre mais il y a différentes
choses qui peuvent se passer par exemple
le cheveux un cas hypothétique la
présence d'un avocat par exemple mais
dépendamment du statut de la personne
qui vient nous rencontrer si elle est
arrêtée mais à ce moment-là
habituellement l'avocat n'est pas
présent ensemble de détention lors des
interrogatoires mais si une personne
vient de son propre gris rencontrer les
enquêteurs à ce moment-là les enquêteurs
n'ont pas de droit à savoir si la
personne est accompagnée ou non d'un
avocat et encore plus si elle est
accompagnée d'un avocat policier serait
très mal avisé d'aller conseiller la
personne sur Oui ou Non est accompagné
c'est même contre le code de déontologie
bon mais quand même quand on parle de
2008 2009 quand il y a eu ces
interrogatoires avec ses victimes
présumées et puis aujourd'hui il y a du
temps qui a passé il y a eu les hashtags
mis tout agressions non dénoncé et les
policiers ont raffiné leur façon de
faire alors considérant le temps qui a
pensé est-ce que c'est possible que ces
vécu à ce moment-là une mauvaise
expérience qui se répéterait pas
aujourd'hui
tout est possible madame Drolet nous au
moment où on se parle il y a rien qui
nous laisse présager qui a eu des
mauvaises pratiques dans le cadre de
Santa quête là ceci dit on a des
enquêteurs en ce moment qui sont en
train de réouvrir le dossier le seul
réapproprier on est prêt au moment où on
se parle on fait appel à des victimes
potentielles ou des témoins potentiels
appelez-nous franchissez cette barrière
ni de l'avant on est prêt à vous
accueillir et on va le faire avec un
très grand professionnel et le
savoir-faire de nos enquêteurs pour
relancer le dossier bientôt vous avez
fait référence à la présence ou pas d'un
avocat pendant que une présumée victime
est interrogée il y a quand même quelque
chose d'un peu spécial qu'on a appris
dans ce reportage c'est que l'avocat
retenu par Monsieur Miller donc pas un
avocat des victimes là l'avocat de
Monsieur Miller aurait été présent dans
la pièce lorsque les policiers parlaient
avec les présumés victimes d'abord
est-ce que c'est un fait qui est exact
est-ce que vous êtes au courant de ça
mais encore une fois madame drelet
malheureusement je peux pas donner des
détails pointus sur cette enquête là
malheureusement pour les mêmes raisons
que je vous ai évoqués et c'est pour ça
que je vous parlais plutôt en général
dans quel genre de circonstances est-ce
qu'un avocat peut être présent mais par
exemple une victime qui se représentée
aujourd'hui pourrait-elle confronté
lorsqu'elle répondent à des questions
des policiers pourrait-elle être dans le
même pièce que l'avocat de Monsieur
Miller
alors le suspect ou l'avocat du suspect
n'a aucun droit de demander d'être
présent quand on rencontre à une victime
quand on rencontre une victime cependant
c'est une victime se présente avec un
avocat et c'est là que les enquêteurs
peuvent pas l'interdire ils peuvent dire
ben écoutez on veut pas vous rencontrer
avec la boca mais c'est la victime du
ben c'est avec la boca ou pas du tout
mais à ce moment-là on va devoir le
rencontrer puis l'autre chose c'est que
les policiers s'ils font des
commentaires des recommandations sur un
professionnel tel qu'un avocat mais
c'est c'est une conduite répréhensible
en vertu du Code de déontologie alors
vous comprenez quand même que quelqu'un
qui se serait essayé à parler avec des
policiers 2008-2009 peut-être quelques
réticences aujourd'hui donc vous vous
dites vous essayez de la convaincre vos
droits vont être respectés et finalement
on a progressé parce que maintenant les
victimes elles ont droit à un
accompagnement on a changé nos façons de
faire bah en fait c'est que c'est
toujours en évolution madame je relève
vous savez la première unité qui est
vraiment améliorée l'accompagnement des
victimes c'est la section agression
sexuelle en 95 ça fait longtemps et
notre section exploitation sexuelle elle
a été officialisée en 2002 donc depuis
ce temps-là on est juste en amélioration
et on a d'ailleurs le programme et
survivants qui vient en aide aux
victimes d'exploitation sexuelle alors
ce qu'il faut dire aux personnes qui
nous écoutent en ce moment c'est fait le
pas appelez-nous on est là pour vous
écouter et vous aurez la décision
éventuellement d'aller jusqu'au bout ou
pas mais on sera quand même là pour vous
accompagner à travers différents
programmes puis avec nos partenaires
aussi tels que les cavacs merci beaucoup
monsieur chaines pour cette intrus